The world's first 3D photo printing booth
gives you the chance to become your own action
figure.
And Los Angeles proudly presents $500 caviar
from a vending machine!
VSauce, Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
A graduate from Design Academy Eindhoven created
a set of cutlery designed to stimulate more
than just your sense of taste.
Synesthesia is a nuerological condition in
which different stimuli such as touch, taste,
and hearing are affected and triggered by
each other.
The different pieces explore the effects of
color and various textures on the senses.
Red colors are supposed to increase the appetite,
and various textures and shapes are intended
to stimulate the sense of touch inside the
mouth with the intention of enriching the
eating experience.
Scientists at MIT have created a tiny transformer.
the Milli-Motein is a re-configurable robot
that can be programmed to fold itself into
a number of different shapes.
Another breakthrough with this robot is that
after it has shifted into a new shape, it
can hold that shape, even when its power is
cut off by using what they call an "electro-permanent
motor."
They do say that there would need to be a
lot of research, as well as cheaper, more
durable parts before a real-life transformer
is created.
Ski Dome Denmark is a vison of the world's
biggest ski-dome in the city of Randers, Denmark.
Designed by a Danish architecture firm, the
proposal includes over 3 KM of indoor and
outdoor slopes, a freestyle park, hotel, restaurant,
and shops.
Resembling a snowflake, the structure consists
of 3 centrally connected arches that each
span the river.
Each arch also uses its roof exterior to connect
the city beyond skiing, such as the bottom
arch having a rooftop of green landscaping
that would function as a raised city park.
Who's hungry for a solid chocolate baby head??
Speaking of chocolate, Cadbury invented its
own melt-resistant chocolate that stays solid
even when left at 104 degrees Fahrenheit for
3 hours!
And it has to do with breaking the sugar particles
into smaller pieces, reducing the amount of
fat covering them, making it more resistant
to heat.
The C-Explorer 5 aims to give people a chance
to finally own a luxury submarine.
For 2.4 million dollars you get seating for
5, air conditioning, an audio system, LED
lighting, and enough air, food, and water
for up to 96 hours in the off-chance you lose
power.
Made by U-Boat Worx, their website boasts
that it's the world's first sub-sea limousine,
and features a 360 degree acrylic pressure
hole so everyone has a view.
The first ever picture of tightly-packed chords
of DNA taken with an electron microscope.
Litographs is bringing books back to the physical
world by printing them on T-shirts.
The first 4 designs are Alice's Adventure
in Wonderland, On the Origin of Species, The
Great Gatsby, and Moby Dick.
The shirts contain all, or most of the book
depending on the size, and the text is completely
legible.
They've already exceded their Kickstarter
goal, check out the website for more.
Created in Japan, the BFS-Auto can read books
at 250 pages per minute, which equates to
an Oxford dictionary in just 10 minutes, or
an entire 32-volume set of Encyclopedia Britannica
in about 2 hours.
It achieves high-definition resolution at
400 pixels per inch, and can compensate for
the three-dimensional deformation of the paper
while being flipped, giving it the ability
to scan thousands of books quickly without
damaging them.
Basically, it's like Johnny 5 from Short Circuit.
Finally, here's a video from M-I-E called
Jammed about the demise of the audio-casette
in the story of a view-master robot venturing
into an unknown world.
I'm gonna leave you with with Disney's prototype
of a humanoid robot playing catch, and, as
always, thanks for watching.